[Music]
how are you I'm good how are you doing
I'm so good great to see you I am my
sister I can't wait to call her after
this she gonna be so jealous yeah you
don't know this but there's actually
this um random thing that happened and
it was um when you in hooting the
Blowfish and my my family they were from
North Carolina and um they were at some
thing that you happened to just stop by
be some house party and I love these
stories because they don't get told
enough but you were so cool to everyone
there like you didn't act like you know
that you're hooting the blow finish yeah
you were like yeah you were like very
cool anyway my sister was there she's
like that dude's like really actually
very cool yeah I just we don't spread
those stories enough so I wanted to
spread that but um you have two kids
that live here right I got two live that
live in the city yeah yeah so you're
Nashville to New York a lot then yeah I
spent a lot of time in New York yeah I
love it do you I do love it but I'm way
too Southern to live here yeah I thought
okay wait I thought that too right cuz
I'm texting but like it once you live
here it's interesting because it does
it's almost like you have these tiny
little vill VES that make up Manhattan
absolutely yeah yeah I lived here for
two years oh you did in 2000 and 2001
and that was the first thing I said when
I walked to my apartment I looked around
and I said yeah I'm way too Southern to
be here but uh well I will say the
apartments here they're closets yes they
are they are but I love this I love this
yeah I do too the energy is very very
cool yeah and your two kids and two
girls right that live here actually two
boy and a girl that live here oh boy and
a girl my oldest lives in Nashville yeah
okay awesome is your is your youngest
just now out of the house you're like an
empty nester yeah are you liking it um I
nothing's really strange nothing really
changed because I've been on the road so
much this year so it's like been that
but uh I miss them I get a a lot you
know you miss seeing them because
they're they're you know you got kids
they're they're I know but they're seven
and nine and I can't imagine them being
like out on their own like doing that
terrifies me a little bit Yeah my son in
about a year grew about 8 in and went
from about 5'8 to 6'4 so that was
congratulations for him yeah for him but
now but now he thinks he can take me and
I keep let boy I got old man strength
I'll kill you but uh yeah but I I I love
it I love it experience yeah I have
experience I will take you down exactly
I so Halloween with kids do you whenever
they were younger I'm this is my first
Halloween here and my my boy it's his
favorite holiday my girl loves Christmas
most but he loves Halloween and so we
really get into costumes did did y'all
do that when they were younger we did we
got the costumes every year they dressed
up as something and uh my favorite
costume ever was uh my son dressed as
Darth Vader and I dressed up as Luke
Skywalker I think he was six and he
walked around at every door he'd go I'm
his father it was very funny it was very
funny does he have a voice like yours
cuz your voice is so distinct he's got a
good voice it's not like mine so much
but he's got a great voice I just mean
it's like yeah your rasp is just so it's
so awesome you said yeah yeah I I try I
try I sometimes like when I'm sick
because that's when my rasp comes out
and I'm singing I like but other than
that it's just really annoying and high
one of those voices for that for all
time you're very
nice I I love it though cuz your your
voice is so distinct but um whatever you
were going around with him um uh did you
have a favorite candy did you because
this is what I do I tell my kids they
can have one like a night right I don't
collect candy but I kind of do because
then when they go to bed I I take some
of theirs yeah I'm a this is a very
unpopular thing but I'm a candy corn guy
I love cand no that's classic I love it
yeah candy corn is classic I'm a Reese's
cup girl not that many stuff
not the mini me too I don't like the
minis the ratio is off for the chocolate
and the peanut butter get out of here
that I don't like the minis and when you
go to somebody's house they got Min like
I like to be the neighborhood like I got
the big chocolate bar we're going to Mr
ruger's House oh my God so we were poor
kids and that's what we' do they'd take
us like other we'd go to the
neighborhoods we be like no you did like
a full butter finger there like it was
like absolutely you did the same thing
we did not trick-or treat in my
neighborhood oh we did that too you did
yeah we didn't we didn't have much in
our neighborhood but um do you believe
in like the supernatural speaking of
like Halloween do you believe in ghosts
and stuff like that I do I don't not
believe but I don't I haven't had like a
real experience I was in college and we
uh me and Dean who plays bass and Hoodie
we we moved into this place and we just
got a bunch of beds for my house that
were around and I had my grandmother's
bed yeah my grandmother had died and I'm
sitting I wake up one 3:00 in my morning
I look at the edge of my bed my
grandmother's stand sitting there and
she sitting there and I sit up and I
wipe my eyes and I go wow and she's
still sitting there and I get and I run
out of my bed and I run to Dean's room
and I was like Dean my grandmother's
ghost is in my room can I sleep in your
bed he went
no I'm not there for you no I went on
the couch yeah you're a grown man go
back to exactly exactly I know does it
scare you or do that's kind of cool it's
scary like to see a ghost it's scary a
little but I believe in that stuff big
time I don't not believe in it I just
don't see it they don't like me or I
don't know they don't show themselves to
me they're like that one's too much I
have to ask you this because when I go
back and look at stuff in the beginning
it kind of I cringe a little when I go
in the and it's the 30th Anniversary
it's coming up of the first record of
hooting the blish so when you when you
listen to that do you are you like me do
you cringe or do you or do you just
still love it and are I don't think I've
listened to correctly of you in 30 years
oh really you know why though people
yeah it's not CU you don't like it's
because you listen to it so much while
so much making it exactly when you're
making a record you listen to it every
day all day you get in the car and You'
listening to it and once you make it it
comes out I I bet I haven't listen to it
30 yeah you have to kind of let it go
unless you're like a show doing it
singing it but I'm going to put it on
here soon cuz 30 years is a long 30
years is incredible believe it yeah what
a blessing yeah it's been great cuz not
everybody has that kind of longevity
it's been C in this industry yeah it's
been crazy yeah well you got a great
voice so you're a great writer when did
you realize because a lot of us sing um
but when did you realize like I don't
feel I feel like I'm a chameleon I Can
Go in different genes but I don't have
like a distinct sound like like a U or
like an Annie Linux or Bono or there's
certain voices that have this like
certain distinct sound when did you
realize like yours was special or when I
was like five cuz your voice were you a
man when you were five were you like
what's up Mom like you were like it
wasn't this deep but you know I can
still sing those Al Green songs up high
but when we were five my mom would tell
me all the time you got to do this for a
living this oh wow special so you had
support right from the beginning from
the beginning wow my mom was behind me
from the very beginning she she knew I
was going to be big before I ever
thought about it wow all right we'll
call her Nostradamus so so did did did
you ever were you that guy that used
your voice for like cuzz I feel like you
got a lot of ladies with that voice you
know what I'm saying like I'm the kind
of person I don't leave voicemails cuz I
sound annoying my voice my talking voice
is very different but yours is like all
sexy did you get a lot of ladies because
of
that it didn't
hurt it didn't hurt it did hurt I a
story about one time uh I guess I was a
freshman in in uh college and I met this
girl she was older that she was a junior
and we talk at a bar and we hang out for
a little while and and one night I'm
just you know drunk and I and she's
living on the first floor of this
apartment building and I go outside and
I'm singing Billy Joel
songs just outside outside her window
and uh she came out and she laughed and
she let me in and we had a beer I'll
leave it at there yes we had a beer we
had a beer yes we had a beer
congratulations on that beer um no
that's I would work that angle too about
that kind of voice i' be like yes ladies
um did you a lot of us too I always run
into musicians and I feel like we all
grow up singing in church did you gr
sing in chur Amazing Grace was
amazing
grace How Sweet the Sound oh let Sav the
rich like me that was my song man I that
song we all have a a goto mine was his
eyes on the sparrow love Grace but his
eyes on the sparrow I think because I
saw Sister Act and I was little I was
like I want to be luren Hill I was like
yeah I was like I loved them I thought
it was so good but those songs I feel
like I I feel like I sing differently
because I have that background you
almost you know there's a bigger purpose
for all of us and it's bigger than you
and when that's instilled at you at such
a young age I think spiritual people
sing differently I agree yeah whatever
your belief is I just mean like I feel
like if you believe in something bigger
than you and outside of yourself it's a
different sound that I agree I think you
sing from your soul yeah you sing from
as far in the depth of your soul you can
and I think that just creates something
really special yeah it's almost like
you're able to put your ego aside cuz
we're told at a very young age like it's
not for you it's for the lord it's not
for you for something big yeah I yeah I
love I love that you just sang on my
show all right all right I heard that
too I love Ed Sheran um I got to work
with him on the voice and you did a song
with him right we did I did we were we
uh I went to I've known Ed for years and
I went to England to write with him and
when I first sat down we writing a song
and he asked me who my first love was
and I said it was my fifth grade
girlfriend Sarah and he asked me these
million questions and then at the end of
the session he's like hey I got one more
song let's write a song about Sarah and
I said you want to write a song about my
fifth grade girl I haven't talked to her
in 45 years and you want to talk and we
wrote a song called Sarah about my fifth
grade girlfriend do you you want to know
why I think that's such a great idea is
that we always I feel like adults always
say like oh their children what do they
know of Love or what do they know of
this and I'm like I think children
they're not jaded yet oh exactly you
know what I'm saying I think that kids
feel everything I I never tell my kids
when they come home and they're seven
and nine but they already are like oh I
love him like and I'm like I truly
believe you probably do with your whole
heart like I'm like you know you
probably going to change your mind but
but I'm just going to let you know but
like but yeah I just think it's such a
pure thing and it's there's no other
experience jading that you know yeah I
agree I love this song that's such a
great songwriter ah I have to ask you
this too because this album art is
beautiful this your mama it's my mom oh
my God what was the idea why did you end
up using this picture uh well that's
that's her nursing school graduation
picture she was 24 at the picture and uh
all of our family has that picture up on
their wall and you know my my mom was so
special to me she was such a great human
being she like I said she was my biggest
supporter my biggest fan and when I when
I when I decided to name the record
Carolyn's boy I knew it was going to be
that picture yeah great picture I love
that I'm like that when I write too I
have I have imagery going I have to like
almost paint a picture in my head while
I'm doing it oh me too yeah every song I
write there's a video in my head me too
okay I thought I was weird you are but
yeah you are but I am
too what do you feel like the best
lesson other than her being so
supportive I imagine you're like that
with your kids because you you were
taught that from a young age but what do
you think the biggest lesson you got
from her was oh believe in yourself yeah
cuz we grew up in a really poor
neighborhood with not much and you know
there was no reason for me to believe
that I was going to be here and make it
but she always instilled in me believ in
yourself you could do whatever you want
that I instill that in my kids and I
believe it that's incredible cuz not all
parents do that you know what I'm saying
like not when I was a kid she instilled
in us that you help people not people
are less fortunate you help people who
need help yeah I tell the story about my
brother I guess I was 10 probably not 10
I was probably seven or eight my brother
was 14 and he went to we had this this
couple that lived in our neighbood and
the husband was in the Navy mhm and so
he went away on the ship and the yard
was grown up and my brother went home
went over and cut her grass and he gave
she gave him $10 and he came home
bragging about the $10 he got and my mom
whooped his butt and told him you take
that $10 back down and you give it back
to her because we don't help people for
money we help people to help people and
that was just something oh wow you had a
great mom
wow very very lucky well we have a
little surprise for you and I was very
excited to be able to do this yeah you
don't know he really doesn't know about
it this is not TV this is real um for
for your many many charitable efforts
over the years and for helping those who
need help CMA is actually honoring you
as humanitarian of the
Year oh my
goodness wow oh that's awesome
wow wow
wow I really did not know that I know I
was like no he really doesn't know I did
not know that all right well let's do
another break darius's latest album is
called Carolyn's boy it's out right now
y'all got to check it out and he's also
designed his own line of NFL gear which
is super cool rad which is available in
stores and online so you'all got to
check that
[Music]
out
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home